je
sexe
on nous demandait vraiment
ok manson ou pokémon
voilà une saga qui dure depuis pas mal
de temps créé par satoshi tajiri en 1996
pokémon et surtout très célèbre pour ses
jeux vidéo
à l'occasion des vingt ans de celui ci
nintendo entrevoit de nouveaux jeux qui
succéderont au précédent en ruby oméga
et saphir alpha je parle évidemment de
pokémon soleil et pokémon l'une encore
très peu d'infos circulent à propos de
ce jeu seul un trailer a été annoncée
par nintendo suite aux deux logos
officiels qu'ils avaient partagé et donc
de nombreuses théories font surface sur
ses deux prochains opus une septième
génération un remake un nouveau gameplay
c'est ce que nous allons voir avec trois
théories que je vous propose bien
évidemment l'émission trois théories
n'ai pas accès qu sur star wars et
d'autres licences et sujet m'intéresse
tout autant allez c'est parti
cette théorie est compréhensible tout de
suite et on s'y attaque dès maintenant
les deux prochains jeux pokémon
s'appelleront en français pokémon soleil
et pokémon lune
lucas légendaire emblématique de la
version argent est reconnu comme le
gardien des mères vivant dans les
abysses il serait associé à pokémon lune
rien qu'à regarder le logo nous pouvons
y voir une forme de pokémon avec des
ailes pourquoi pas l'ouguiya ensuite
pokémon sun serait associé à aux
gardiens des cieux ohé ohé limite
synonyme de beau temps et d' arc en ciel
il serait donc le pokémon inspirant le
soleil et j'ai même envie d'aller plus
loin
ces deux pokémon ancestraux représente
donc la nuit et le jour comme il est dit
dans leur histoire et son maître du trio
oiseaux légendaire soit elector arctique
odin et sulfureux pour symboliser encore
plus ces deux points et être le symbole
du soleil et l'autre de la lune comme
pour groudon ekyog louga et or auraient
donc tous les deux une prime aux
résurgences ou bien pourquoi pas une
méga évolution vous imaginez un méga
luzia ou un primo haut mais je m'égare
restons plus rationnelle admettons que x
et y soit le début d'une nouvelle ère
pour pokémon comme le furent rouge et
bleu pokémon sun et pokémon moon serait
alors le or et argent de l'époque
pour commencer nous sommes aux 20 ans de
pokémon nintendo pour fêter ça fait
énormément de choses comme de nouvelles
applications des pokémon distribué etc
nous annonce de nouveaux jeux pour la
fin d'année
je pense sincèrement qu'ils voudront
mettre le paquet et pour relier ceci à
pokémon or et argent
pensez au remake de ceux ci la région et
16 pages
c'est peut-être ce qu'il nous attend
pour énormément ce n'est moon seront la
suite de pokémon x et y qui nous laisse
un peu sur notre faim avec quelques
mystères non résolus
pensons à certains endroits comme la
gare ou bien la centrale qui doivent
bien mener quelque part ou encore la
ville que l'on peut apercevoir près de
la ligue pokémon ou bien l'homme qui
prétend devenir d'aucune des régions
déjà existantes et qui nous donne un
souvenir ressemblant un pokémon
inexistant tout ceci nous fait rêver
bien entendu il est fort probable que
ces mystères est un lien avec cette
nouvelle région
cependant pour cette théorie un leak des
noms des deux prochains légendaire du
jeu ont été repérés par des fans ce qui
contredit leurs remakes de pokémon or et
pokémon argent mais il se peut qu'il y
ait une référence à orthe heart gold et
argent soul silver
parlons un peu des nouveaux logos mais
d'abord qu'est ce que la synergie à
synergy est un type de phénomène par
lequel plusieurs facteurs agissant en
commun ensemble créer un effet global
comme qui dirait une fusion la synergie
est présente dans poker tournament et
est représenté par un losange
celui ci nous permet d'entrer en contact
avec notre pokémon qui voit cette
pouvoir se développer voire même méga
évolué prenons le temps de regarder les
logos des prochains jeux nous apercevons
deux petits losanges
si nous regardons les précédents logo
des anciens pokémon nous apercevons pour
x y
le signe de la méga évolution et pour
rubis oméga et saphir alpha le signe de
la prime aux résurgences où je veux en
venir c'est qu'il serait fort probable
qu'un nouveau pouvoir arriverait dans
les prochain pokémon
elle se serait la synergie représenté
par le losange en juin poken nous voyons
clairement que ce logo représente la
synergie
il est présent tout le long de
l'aventuré solo à l'icf et rome
n'utilise même en tant que symbole et si
nous allons plus loin
regardons les limites pokémon nous y
retrouvons aussi la synergie avec le en
fine au but de sascha d'après le site
officiel lorsque le lien qui unit sacha
et son pokémon atteint son maximum il
entre en synergie ce dernier prend
l'apparence de son dresseur on voit
clairement qu en finn hobby appelé aussi
sa chan aubry ressemble comme deux
gouttes d'eau à son dresseur je ne pense
pas du tout qu'il s'agisse d'un hasard
et que nintendo veut vraiment introduire
la synergie dans ses prochains jeux
on pourrait alors avoir un pokémon qui
nous aimant au maximum ne ressemblerait
et si nous pourrions changer de
vêtements comme dans x et y
qu'est ce qu'il se passera pour le
pokémon du coup
plusieurs choses apparaîtront donc dans
ces deux prochains jeux mais quelles
seront ses nouveautés on a déjà émis
l'hypothèse de la synergie et d'une
aventure assez ce badge d'après de
nombreuses théories cette région pokémon
serait proche de carlos afin de
permettre aux différents un retour et
obtenir 16 badges et profitant d'une
aventure très longue pour les 20 ans de
pokémon de plus le trailer nous l'a très
bien montré pokémon sonne et pokémon
moon semble réellement ouvrir les portes
à une nouvelle génération de pokémon
soit la septième nous le remarquons très
facilement avec le leak d'un pokémon
oiseaux ne ressemblant à aucun déjà
connu jusqu'à présent les dresseurs et
champion d'arène aurait donc des équipes
revisité exprès pour l'occasion pour ne
pas répéter xy et nous rappellerait
pokémon or heartgold et argent
soulsilver ensuite un nouveau gameplay
encore plus stratégique ferait son
apparition dans ses prochains jeux car
nous avons déjà les méga évolution
disponible seulement à une part combat
mais cette fois ci nous aurons plus à
synergy qui développera les pouvoirs des
pokémon est ce que la synergie il serait
plus puissante que la méga évolution
tout comme celle ci elle s'effectue par
le biais d'une pierre soit une pierre de
synergies est ce que dans un combat nous
pourrions avoir un pokémon méga évoluer
un pokémon en synergie ou bien seulement
l'un des deux tant de mystère enfin
n'oublions pas s'ils gardent ces deux
nouvelles formes ne sont pas là par
hasard et pour moi comme pour d'autres
il serait fort probable que l'histoire
tourne autour d'eux y garde et de ses
formes 10 50 et 100% en lien avec ce
qu'on vient de dire qui nous dit que
s'ils gardent n'entre pas en synergie
lorsqu'il atteint les 100%
après tout la synergie décuple les
forces du pokémon en question je sais
qu'il faut que les blogs qui sont
considérés comme les 1% doivent se
réunir pour atteindre les autres formes
mais justement ils se réunissent et
entre en fusion
ça ne vous rappelle pas quelque chose
la synergie pour finir un petit bonus
qui me tenait à coeur
tout le monde connaît le pokémon 731
inventé pour une crypte pasta en rapport
avec l'avant ville et bien s'il ya en
tout 7 121 pokémon sans compter le
récent dévoilé on approche du 731 m
si on compte les starters ça fait 9 on
arrive à 730 un hasard en général ce qui
suit les starters est un pokémon oiseaux
celui montré dans le trailer complot
coïncidence je ne sais pas mais ça
serait marrant de voir une référence aux
pokémon 731 le pokémon bug je ne
parlerai pas de la théorie de la
prochaine région je préfère vous laisser
voir la vidéo de pokémon trash qui a
fait une excellente théorie sur celle ci
plein de mystère entoure ces deux
prochains jeux et pokémon sun et pokémon
moon nous réserve bien des surprises
n'hésitez pas à interagir via les
commentaires de la vidéo c'est important
pour moi
merci à ceux qui partageront la vidéo
que le line up soit avec vous vive
pokémon et notre enfance c'était argot
rock